what is going on everybody welcome to a
new tutorial series where I show you how
you can make your very own machine
friend that you can talk to for example
I have my friend here let's see what
they have to say so first we'll start
off with some some pretty pressing
questions like do you like pancakes I
like turtles
okay what about what is the color of the
sky what is the color of the sky the
color of the blue
okay okay did you vote for Hillary
Donald or Donald I voted for the
president okay okay let's ask some more
pressing questions that we really need
to know the answers for what is the best
song song ever
darrid sandstorm no arguments there
what is the universe is the universe the
universe is a lot at least I have my
friend so you know are you my pal buddy
are you my pal buddy he is I'm not your
pal friend that really hurt my feelings
why would you hurt me I'm not your buddy
I'm just a little bit of a dick so the
initial purpose for me to make a chatbot
was I was hoping to have some sort of
chat bot that could converse with
viewers on the twitch stream of the
self-driving car ai plays GTA stream and
in that basically it's a chat bot that
you could pretty much use everywhere you
wouldn't have to necessarily use the
exact same source that I used for
training data and all that but the
methodology pretty much stays the same
and really just like any task with
machine learning the biggest thing is
just getting the data and manipulating
the data to be useful
so anyways with that as I started to
look into okay how do we actually go
about making a chat bot in Python and
tensorflow I found a bunch of examples a
bunch of like weak ways to make chat
BOTS it's nothing that was gonna be
super robust also I had a little bit of
trouble trying to find like a decent
data set to actually do it so one of the
more common data sets that people tend
to or seem to be using is like this this
Cornell movie database which contains
220,000 conversational exchanges between
ten thousand three hundred pairs of
movie characters so this one's actually
a super common one to be used for a
variety of reasons you've got the
different movies you've also got
different as it says here different
genders different characters stuff like
that so we can kind of begin to pull
these apart but I didn't really like the
fact that we only have 220,000 exchanges
I wanted to be able to find something
that had even more than that that way if
you really did want to pare it down to
really specific situations you'd like to
have much more data so anyways I
continued my search and I found myself
on thinking like well what about read it
because reddit has basically you know
just tons of comments on tons of topics
it's all sorted for you and all of that
so I thought hey I want to use reddit so
my first thought was I'll use the Python
reddit API I'll go through that and I'll
just start parsing from reddit over time
well the writing API has a pretty strict
API limitations I forget what they are
now I mentioned it in this tutorial but
it's nothing that's gonna let you be
able to even parse like millions of rows
without a long period of time or
violating the Terms of Service so so
moving along I ended up stumbling across
this awesome data set post from two
years ago but basically you can read the
title it's I have every publicly
available reddit comment and basically
it's everyone I I don't really know the
start date of Reddit to be honest but I
believe this goes all the way back to
2000 I can't remember but anyways it
goes quite a ways back we'll see in a
little bit anyway
but it's one point seven billion
comments which is a lot that's a lot
more than 220,000 so so basically if
you're not familiar with Reddit welcome
to the internet basically reddit is a
place of toxis it's a place where people
get to talk with each other anyway here
we have a few few options and for this
tutorial if you really want if you want
to follow along you have also a few
options first of all you can this would
be yes so this is for just one month of
comments that will be more than enough
to create a chat bot that is pretty good
that will be like the one that you saw
in the beginning of this video so you
can download the torrent for that and
use your favorite torrent I don't
doesn't really matter and then or
torrent program rather and then there's
also this is the full torrent now I've
downloaded this on multiple occasions
mostly because like I tried to move this
to a machine in the cloud and I didn't
want to upload it so I just read
downloaded it and the first time I
downloaded it it actually went really
quick the full archive the second time I
tried to download it it was horribly
slow like it took days which was
unfortunate because I was paying for the
machine so you know try it out and if
it's too slow maybe try the one month
because you really can you really can't
get by with just the one month but it's
cool to have all the data again for you
know if you want to go through it and be
really specific so for example you could
you could train an algorithm to work
purely on specific subreddit so it's
kind of funny as it when I found this
somebody somewhere was suggesting that
someone even like they were like excited
that someone might do that in the future
anyway it's so we're in there but
interesting the other option that you
have is this one right here it's it's a
it links to a comment about 1.7 loaded
on it being query but it's actually even
more than that so let me pull it up real
quick great so anyway there's this table
but as you can see it actually goes all
the way to current
so it's currently November so it doesn't
have the full table but anyways these
are all the comments right so on big
query unfortunately I'm just an idiot
and I apparently can't write good
bigquery queries and I found it to be
very cost prohibitive to work off
bigquery but if one of you kind viewers
happens to figure out how to write a
really efficient bigquery poll so we can
actually pull I would love to be able to
pull very recent tables so the 1.7
billion comment download or the torrent
only goes up to May of 2015 so it has no
idea like for cough fa is not in his
vocabulary right so it would be cool to
have a more current chat bot so yeah if
anybody knows how to do it like I said I
couldn't get polls to be big enough to
be like cost effective like I just think
I pulled maybe I don't know less than a
hundred thousand rows if I recall right
and then up cost me thirty dollars
I don't know no no clue how that
happened but it did so so I stopped yeah
so you can get that data set there and
like I said you can either use bigquery
you can download the torrent and really
you can get by with just a month's worth
of comments and really the further you
come down like there's gonna be way more
comments in the month of October of 2017
then the last one which was May 2015
I think May of 2015 had like 60 million
comments and then once you have them if
you actually go to Reddit just
understand basically the structure I've
read it if you don't don't understand it
so we can just go to like the home page
here and as you can see you've got like
parent comments and then every child is
like a response to that parent and then
you might have multiple responses and it
kind of just comes out in this tree form
and so what we need to do is actually
pull these apart and start start to pair
them together in parent-child or comment
and reply manner which can take a little
bit of processing and all that but it's
not something that we can't do so
anyways that's going to be our goal and
this is going to be the data set that we
want to use so I'm actually going to cut
it here just simply because downloading
the data set it's probably gonna take
but once you have one of the examples if
you do use bigquery by the way your
formats gonna be probably different than
what we're using here but I really do
want to see a big query pole so if
someone does it please do share anyways
once you have the data and you're ready
to go you'll be good for the next
tutorial
and I'll see you in that